let's think a little bit about how we
can tell whether our body is processing
glucose properly and whether maybe we we
have diabetes and I want y'all to take
all of this with a huge grain of salt
because I am NOT a doctor this is not
medical advice my goal here is to kind
of just explore the subject with you and
to try for all of us to get a better
understanding of things so let's think
about what might happen after we have a
meal so let me draw a little chart over
here so let's call this let's call this
hours hours and then on the vertical
axis I'm gonna talk about our
concentration of sugar in the blood so
blood sugar concentration blood sugar or
I sure
you could call it glucose concentration
blood sugar concentration we're talking
about blood blood sugar we're talking
about glucose concentration and let me
draw a couple of points on this chart so
maybe this is 50 and our units are going
to be milligrams per deciliter and
actually let me just do it this way let
me just say that everything is in
milligrams per deciliter and we'll talk
in the future videos about well what
kind of how we can relate these units to
to everyday terms but let's say that
this right here is 50 this right here is
100 this right here is 150 and let's
mark it right here at 200 so let's think
about what would happen for a normal
person let me mark some hours over here
so our one two three four five six seven
eight that's probably good enough so in
a normal person when they haven't eaten
anything for a long time let's say
greater than eight hours so they're
fasting blood sugar will be right around
80 milligrams per deciliter give or take
a little bit there's a range around that
but I just want to show you what would
happen to a normal person so in 80 80
milligrams per deciliter their blood
sugar will kind of be should hopefully
be right around there and some
time's this fasting blood sugar and
maybe we're assuming that this is in the
morning so maybe this hour one is seven
in the morning so they haven't eaten for
a while and that's what's fasting blood
sugar this is also you'll hear and kind
of feel sometimes your doctors when I've
heard my wife say this word without
knowing what it meant they'll sometimes
say pre prandial pre / and eel which is
a very fancy word which just means
before a meal prandial is literally
before eating after the meal you're
talking postprandial so it's a very
fancy word for a very simple idea eating
so let's say an hour to this individual
eats breakfast so this is right this is
where the individual is going to eat
breakfast now in a normal person when
that person eats breakfast it'll be some
carbohydrates some carbohydrates in that
breakfast and it will be broken down
into glucose and that glucose will enter
the bloodstream and so their blood
glucose will go up their blood glucose
will go up it'll slowly go up and I was
reading some studies they say it kind of
it kind of spikes at about 45 minutes
into a meal so let's see 45 minutes is
over there so maybe it'll go up to about
there and in a normal individual the
blood glucose really shouldn't go up
above 120 milligrams per deciliter now
you know there's obviously exceptions to
all of these we're just kind of saying a
normal breakfast a normal person they're
not you know they're not eating a pint
of honey they're not doing something
crazy so let's say 120 would be right
around right around there a normal
person you wouldn't someone who does not
have diabetes it would be unlikely that
it would go above that and then actually
after about 2 hours they're getting
pretty close to normal to get back under
a hundred milligrams per deciliter and
then you go beyond two hours they just
kind of get close back to their baseline
to that eighty milligrams per deciliter
so once again this is this is normal and
of course you know don't freak out if
you were to take a blood test one
morning and you are at like eighty five
milligrams per deciliter you're still
not far off from normal so obviously
there's some variation from person to
person
now if someone has diabetes if either
they don't have type 1 there they don't
have enough insulin to actually process
the glucose or if they have enough
insulin but their body is desensitized
to it the insulin isn't being processed
properly so they can't process the
glucose we've seen that the glucose
concentrations will go up and so in
general if you were to wake up one
morning after not having eaten for more
than eight hours and you were to pick
your prick your finger with one of those
little glucose monitors you can get at
the drugstore and in your and in your
finger the the blood sugar levels if you
were to find them to be let's say you
were to find them to be at 100 let's say
140 140 that's 140 milligrams per
deciliter it's a good indication I mean
you shouldn't freak out you should do
multiple tests and make sure that that
you know it wasn't the false reading or
any of that and you should definitely
see a doctor once again don't view this
as any type of medical advice that is
not the purpose of this the purpose of
this is just to understand a little bit
of what's going on don't don't yeah
don't change your lifestyle based on
anything I tell you all right so if you
but if you do experience to that it
looks like at least just from that one
data point that your body isn't
processing sugar properly because you've
had over eight hours to process the
sugar for insulin to go in your
bloodstream and allow glucose to be
taken up and get back down to a normal
level but it still hasn't gone there so
if you were to if you were to test of a
value like that you you should you
should be concerned in general the
threshold and I've I've seen multiple
thresholds here are between 100 and I've
seen high kind of mid 120 s to 130
milligrams per deciliter so that's kind
of let me do it in this range it's kind
of if you are above if your fasting
blood sugar is above this line right
here remember the fasting blood sugar
not after you've eaten a meal your pre
prandial before a meal if it is above
that threshold right over there then you
should at least you should definitely
see a doctor and make sure that they can
they can you know see if you if you have
diabetes but this would be cause for
concern the other thing is it's after a
meal it spikes well beyond that if we're
talking if it gets above a
180 and you know once again these are
all just thresholds that people you know
doctors have come up with and
researchers have come up with and say
hey this is a good indication that
somehow you are not processing glucose
properly so 180 180 is up here and I'm
drawing it as a squiggly line because
it's kind of a range it's not like you
know it's not like if 100 if your blood
glucose is 124 you're safe and all of a
sudden 125 you have diabetes no they're
you know they're not that different than
each other but they have to set up some
threshold so that just to kind of have a
threshold I guess so if your blood sugar
after eating a meal we're to spike up to
let's say 200 once again that would be
cause for concern so in general if
someone has diabetes because they're not
processing the glucose properly after
their their blood glucose might look
something like this so maybe their
fasting blood glucose is right around
125 130 it can move around then they
have a meal then it might spike up and
they might have obviously they can
process some of the glucose otherwise
they would they would die but it's not
being processed properly so the glucose
levels don't go down to where they
should and maybe you get some some
glucose gets taken up from the blood
obviously they're living so their cells
are metabolizing something but it never
gets down to the normal 80 milligrams
per deciliter it might go it might
settle down back to something in the 120
range or something like that which would
be cause for concern and in general if
you're someplace in je I've seen the
threshold if you're above 100 and it on
a fasting basis that's cause for concern
you should maybe adjust your lifestyle
and if you're above if you if you're
above 120 130 after a meal once again
this you should also be slightly worried
that you might maybe are pre-diabetic or
you have some risk of that developing
diabetes so this is what this is a high
if someone has blood sugar like this
they're probably diabetic and if someone
has blood sugar like this they should be
they should be worried but once again I
am NOT a doctor don't take any of this
as an advice this is really just our
attempt to to
standings a little bit better